Charlede l'Association des prods
d'arbres de Noël du Québec.
Bonsoi
- Bonsoir.
- Est-ce qu'il y a une pén
où ces personnes que on envoie
encore plus aux États-Unis?
- ne veut pas dire pénurie,
c'est ce qu'on s'en énorme
demande cette année les
producteurs ont moins d'arbres a
être dépendamment la demande du
consommateur.
d'arbres cette année. C'est le
gène et la s
- oui, mais par contre il faut
prendre en compte l'arbre de en2
ans avant d'atteindre sa pleinee
suite à cette pied. Donc, dans
les années 2008 et 2010, il
était a crise
économique. Beaucoup moins, les
prix étaient à la baisse. Les
producteurs ont soif et
faillite laissaite laissaite las
aller parce que veut ou veute cé
était juste plus là. Là, c'est
fait ressentir présentement où
nos conos conos conos conos cons
d'arbres.
- Donc il y a huit ans on n'en a
moins planté. Donc ça ne peutvin
d'années?- les plus grands, un e
neuf à 10 pieds, on peut parler
de 14 à 15 ans. Nous, les
producteurs, acheter un arbre de
Noël que déjà avoir cinq ans
c'est un plan, et vont
probablement être un pied ou un
pied et demi. On parle
pratiquement de 12 ans regarder
réchauffement climatique, les
ailes printaniers, les
sécheresses, nous complique
encore plus la vie produire
d'arbre de Noël.
- C'est vrai que nous avons
davantage aux États-Uni
- c'est ce qu'il y a une f
demande aux É
seulement au Québec ou au
Canada, cette re
marché global et les États-Unis
ont vécu la même chose en 2008
et en 2010 et ou
acheteurs sont venus faire le
tour de plusieurs producteurs
pour pouvoir ach
- Est-ce que ça reste une bonne
affair
on le dit, les prix ont
producst payant?st payant?st pa?
- C'es
fois, on ne veut pas notre
client, on ne peut pas traîner
notre clientèle. On ne peut pas
faire mal à notre part de marché
qu'on a gagné parce que veut ou
veut pas, on a toujours eu la
bagarre entre l'arbre de Noël
ciel et l'arbre de Noël
naturel. Je ne pense pas que
l'arbre de Noël naturel par des
plumes à cause du prix. Oui, ça
va se rétablir au courant des
prochaines années, et comme jevr
augmenté de grosse augmentationa
se faire sentir cette année,
mais on ne veut pas monter
exponentiellement non plus.
- On voit que les tradition des